alone a very warm welcome to another
edition of talking germany the show
where we do just that and my guest today
is the outstanding film director and
producer nicole hoffman and here he is
in person thank you very very much for
joining us here today on taking germany
wonderful great stuff now it's
absolutely astonishing i can tell you
how many films nucca hoffman has been
involved in his devotion to the business
is i think it's fair to say almost manic
and his special fascination is making
movies about germany's difficult recent
history indeed it has been said that
nickel hoffman is obsessed with german
history in here you're smiling a wee
little bit as i say that but it's it's
not just been said of you i have a quote
about you you said of yourself i am
obsessed by german history and then you
added to such an extent in fact that it
is not normal i did i did say that you
where does it all come from actually i
think it started really buy buy my own
family stories in my minimal family and
i was trained as a journalist and during
the trading time i studied some research
on on the story of my family in in
mannheim where I come from and in the
moment where you start to discuss the
own family background the own family
biographies you immediately come to the
part of the Suraj and you ask your
parents what have you done as a soldier
what have you done as a punt torture
matron my mother was very young she was
14 when the soutache ended and so
immediately you you start to discuss
your family stories also in the times
between 33 and 45 ok that's what we're
going to be talking about today is gonna
be very interesting let me just move on
a little bit to set out the agenda a wee
bit there was a journalist who was
writing about your work in the in the
last you know many years and he said
nikka Hoffman has probably on his own
made more films about German history in
the last ten years than all the other
people in the 40 years before yeah and
then that journalist said the you
learning the yearning among Germans for
these films is almost unlimited hmm how
do you explain that yearning now and I'm
not sure if it's still a yearning I
would say indeed yes in the last 15
years i think i've produced 25 30 films
touching or directly touching the
subject of the cerclage really really a
lot of them and many of them like
traceton which was also shown in in
England as I think the BBC showed it or
even much of millions about the refugees
coming directly in 45 from the eastern
so-called parts of Germany fleeing from
the Russians it true really 11 12 13
million audiences each evening for two
three parts though that was amazing as
it was amazing that there was such a
inner need for discussion about
emotional backgrounds what have happened
in those days for example people having
survived the bombardment interest they
wanted to talk in their own families
about their memories on these days and
it's amazing for me that you needed this
very special emotional filmic adaptation
of all these events that people are now
in the year twisting was shown in 2006
that you need to film that people in
2006 were able to speak out very openly
about their feelings in those days so
this was something amazing for me but
that's a reason for the further for the
big success of all these films
the Goldman I'd like to go back to your
early days to your student days when you
were when you were at film school you
made it you made a short movie wasn't
quite an hour long as far as I know
called Deer Creek minus far tease yeah
my father's war whoops what was the
story there actually it was a diary from
her father about his first days in the
war that he rode on every day and then
office war time and the film was made in
a period in Germany where you had this
huge discussion about the natto double
brushless that was the idea to put more
Rockets on charm and soil against the
Russians was a big debate it was the
first time in those days that people in
Germany really feared a new war could
could could be on the front could be
happening and the the film school was at
all my students everybody was discussing
could be it could be could we have a
subject like the war in our first movie
we are doing at the film school and I
picked I picked not the modern
questioning I picked the questioning
after the memories and after after the
experience of Mount of my own father and
that was a big that was the beginning of
a big debate was in the film within the
family what happened in those days but
experience emotional experience he had
it was in some ways a starting point of
generation war the big hit that was now
shown when sam adams of phaidor three
weeks ago here we'll come to that in
just a second but the your first
full-length movie we just saw a little
extract from it there in that report
that was 1988 I think you by this time
you were a professional filmmaker by
this stage you made this movie lunch
their fatal under zone a land of the
fathers hmm just tell me a little bit
about that one as well because this is
another movie about a father story
lender father son of sons was the idea
that the same actor playing the Son and
the father both were the same vector so
I slipped into the role if you want so
of my own of the generation of my father
and in addition to that the film was
also
he was also researching in a very
special way it was not only the story of
my own father it was a story of two
other friends of my father in Mannheim
concerning their story in the third hive
so it was a really real based on fact
research story what happened in those
days it was playing in Poland part of
the film were shot in Poland but the
interesting thing for me was I was
putting myself if you want so as a
script water I was putting myself in the
same role as father and of Sun and I
played some psychology I played the the
rism of the lives of the fascist through
my own eyes that was idea behind a
lender father son of sons very
intriguing you've mentioned your father
already you've mentioned your mother
already we've mentioned German history
you grew up with German history
literally literally bring brought into
the house where where you were growing
up your your mother and your father were
both journalists at the time and they
were very well-connected generous they
were very very connected to the
political scene my father was working
for the hind paws he was a chef from
tins and he later on worked in Bonn he
was very close to really plan to Helmut
Schmidt especially to Helmut Kohl helmut
kohl was indeed visiting us many times
he was close living in analytics of him
but another another important thing was
it's a Mannheim film vaca the Manama
film week was a very important festival
on those days and all the big big
directors from the eastern parts of
Germany like me lost Foreman many people
from Poland we're really coming to our
family oh really yeah and it was it was
if you want so it was every evening we
had a very very interesting discussion
with people from all over the world
about cinema about art and about
politics so that was a very my childhood
before my parents were separated it was
a very very interesting time of my life
definitely you were initially a film
director now you are a film producer
that's really how you've made your name
in
in the big market as it were why did you
make the transition yeah i was quite i
would say i was quite talented as a film
director and i had my ups and downs at
the end of the career I was sorry to see
you smiling as you think back to those
yeah it was not only easy it was it was
a yeah you have successes you have
failures but at the end of the day when
I was 35 I started a very new film
school close to Stuttgart it's called
Film Academy baden-württemberg and I was
a teacher and I really felt that it had
so many students being more talented
than I've felt for myself it was
especially one one guy he was 22 he was
so incredibly talented and I produced
the films of them as I had 15 20
students each year I was a producer of
their student films and at the same time
I was working for banishing up and
Archana was one of the big personalities
he was number one is he still is even if
even two years after his debt he's still
the Chairman film producer of Adi of
decades and he will never be replaced
and I was working for band and I I got
the feeling how great and how
interesting it could be if you're really
if you're really creatively producing if
you really put all your creation into
production and that gave me within two
or three years I really got the energy
to say okay I stopped the career as a
director and irie I make a complete
reset in my life and I really restart it
was a new produce and company and that
was a restart when I was such a seven
and thankful it was a very good
experience and you talk there about
putting everything into movies putting
everything maybe into a specific movie
project our mothers our fathers this
most recent project of yours are one of
the certainly the most outstanding
project here to be much discussed huge
controversy I think it's as well yeah
just just map out for us a wee little
bit what it's about noble of a quick
look it's it's about five young people
between 41 and 45 in Germany
one of them is Jewish and two girls two
boys and the last boys Jewish he escapes
to Poland on a way towards a
concentration camp and it's their life
and their stories and it's alive like
the title is called of my of the
generation of my parents
there's a great project removing project
for me personally I would say a very
personal project for you we've
established that and it's got an awful
lot to do with your relationship with
your father as I understand it there was
one very specific day that you met with
him in New York or you spent with him in
New York tell us mother yeah it was my
parents got separated so that was a huge
divorce going on and was very hurting me
a lot and at the end of all these crazy
discussions before my father left for
another women and he went went together
with me to New York for I was 14 and we
stayed there for one week and I started
really I was very aggressive totally
aggressive and I started to talk with
him about the divorce and why he wanted
to go and why he's so crazy peaceful and
he's not struggling for me especially
and we came to the wartime experience as
we came after three days he started to
talk about his experience in life his
experience killing other people his
experience to survive we're in in war
times and it was a the the topic changed
from from his personal story to his
personal story during wartime and Edmund
I was I was 14 and I i was totally
overwhelmed with his feelings I couldn't
get that organized in any way what he
wanted said understandable I understand
was like it was very tough to understand
it what she wanted and then he left and
crazy enough in
I slept two or three weeks at the side
of my mother and I was a little bedside
chair and in this better better chair he
left his photos and his the medallions
and all that stuff he got in in wartime
so everything he left before he went to
his new family in ludwigshafen was his
last pieces of vatta memories that was
crazy i was 14 and I kept that stuff
with me for all those days and then I
restarted the process six years ago as
especially after trace in the twist so
you needed all that time tiny giant yeah
because we had a very tricky difficult
relationship that was not easy
relationship but I really wanted I told
i told him before he would die I would
love to have this discussion longer and
longer again but where these important
years for him because these three or
four years where the most also
negatively the most awesome
psychologically very very destructive
way where the most deciding years in his
life hmm was a 14 year old your father
tells you that he killed you just said
you didn't say a person you said people
yeah yeah yeah what does that do to a 14
year old I mean I come from a military
family but nobody told me that this
happened I don't think it did yeah yeah
you first of all you have no imagination
what it means but the much more
problematic thing was that you know in
sherman schools and this is a very very
very okay for me it's very clear that
the Nazi crimes the since your family
have done in the Nazi time I all all
family members being connected to the
Sahaj in my family half of them were
conducted to the third Maj they they're
gangsters they were not only gangsters
ever murderers the we're outcasts there
were the most negative people when you
were 15 years old in school term and you
read German literature in
in history lessons in school time you
immediately choose the position of the
Jewish side as a year saying okay if I
who if I would be free to be asked I
would love to be true and not to be at
ramen so deep really so deep in the
question of guilt and it's a question of
what half has this generation done to
the whole world was in my mind so your
own father says to you okay but I killed
Russian soldiers that was the top of the
discussion emotionally because that was
something for me I could absolutely not
let through to me absolutely not when I
was 15 years old and one of the
questions you're asking yourself I'm
sure while you're being involved in this
project is how would I have acted at the
time yeah the first question is how
would I have acted in those days and the
next question is and there you need much
more material that was possibly here
with Jenna reservoir is a question how
could it be that the whole nation really
comes to this kind of absolutely
terrible engagement against the whole
world against Jews against the Polish
people against the Russians this is
really a question for me perhaps it
started in those days and between school
term and personal debates within the
family perhaps it was a time where it
started all over in me but there is
surely the point in my life where this
whole discussion began and it ended if
you want so with this last film i
certainly don't want to pry into your
private life but when i was reading
about you when I was researching about
you there was one thing there were a lot
of things that shocked me because we're
talking about German history in German
history is shocking but there was one
thing about you as a person who's you
you have been traumatized by what went
on between the generations and I read
that you as a youngster this must have
been at the same time you filmed your
parents having arguments the I did that
here sure that was part of Maya this is
shocking this is shocking to me oh yeah
I don't know if it's shocking I mean I
was studying filmmaking this
seven eight years it started with a
super 8 camera and is typically a lot of
my film students today this started with
a video camera when there were eight
years old but in the beginning it was
just fun but cheering the lifetime
between 15 16 17 we're really all these
DVD series I had a very had a very
aggressive and very I would say it's a
interesting discussions within my family
about everything and everybody really I
had I was struggling with my mother I
was struggling with my middle with my
father I was struggling about their past
I was struggling with my grandmother I
was very aggressive and then the
filmmaking and and to film it I was
really I was willing making I really
made a film about the divorce of my
parents live in the living room of proof
of our house at linden ave manam and yet
were two actors and they were playing
for one full week all yeah all deeper
it's all craziness i had in my family
but that was something like a therapy
and surely it was a therapy for the next
year's on film school when I was a film
student when I have another look to my
former films all these films were very
very yeah it would be kind of family
therapy in some way okay let's come back
to the to the to how you dramatize
history when you make when you make a
film out of history your father told you
the story and you're thinking I want to
tell that story that you've sometimes
being criticized for using too much
emotion mmm because history what really
happens reality is cold it's dirty it's
dark it's cruel it's unpleasant there's
no background music in your movies
there's background music people
sometimes talk of you know elements of
kitsch I know you don't like that so how
do you answer that i would say i changed
the portfolio of the films and the
making of the films in the last six or
seven years it changed dramatically if
you have a look to a film like tres noir
much of millions called de Flore stem
ceremony
the structures of the films they're very
melodramatic it was a very melodramatic
structure it had a love affair plot in
the middle of the storyline but
nevertheless if you take trace which was
the biggest hit in selling overseas the
second part of trace and everything is
about authenticity everything you see
you feel you get in the second part is
really was really happening interest and
so it's not kitsch it's not overwhelming
with feelings and melodramatic
structures but i changed it and if you
take the films of the last two years I
really came back to very realistic very
authentic setting if you take to a
narration for when some add-ons for
theta it's very authentic that the music
is very very minimalistic it's not a big
orchestral music so i changed it because
people are now I was especially saying
Charlie people are now they are now
capable also intellectually capable
really should take the films even if
they also pure and though hard so hard
as they have been here with generation
wrong it was not clear if this is a
success or not a success many people in
the television companies not only on set
f sites is that this will be a tragedy
nobody will will watch it but it was not
the case
burnout is something that you know about
yet what can you report your a nice
question actually I had a big burn out
at about three years ago it happened
after one of the films were not so
publicly acclaimed as I wanted to have
it and it didn't work how many films
have you directed or produced produced
that's that how many a lot i would say
100 yeah more than 100 as a we are now I
think we are nearly 300 no with some
team works it's so it's a it's huge but
it was a film corner one of the name
then sometimes floor sometimes sometimes
there's a firmware really i would tell
you even if channa reservoir yeah when
so medals of theta if it would have been
a big failure if nobody would have
watched it would have been you would
have been in danger yeah absolutely i'm
not in danger but i think i would really
in the moment if you if you invest
really a lot of time a lot of energy and
you love the project and then it's
absolutely not working you start really
to reflect okay what are the reasons mmm
was the wrong way what is the future
what should i do the future with other
topics so this was the cancer it was
wasn't the limit no the bar that was
caught in the exact translation would be
the borderline it but I reestablished
the borderline between East and West
Germany my feeling was it all comes back
and I wanted to have it as a as a future
outlook and it was was a sum of the
parts of the film way okay other ones
were totally crazy but the critics they
hated it the audience was quite okay at
the second part it dropped down
dramatically and that came together with
really 10 years of permanent verb 20
films a year and then you get you get on
some kind of on a cero level where you
really feel care absolutely no energy
anymore to energize me and that was a
reason so yeah well what are they I mean
there are people who work hard clearly
you do yeah there are people who are
called workaholics I'm never quite sure
what that means and then there's burnout
syndrome yeah what are what you know
what are the signs that you've got
from one to the next and into burn out I
think the crucial point is if you if you
work and you don't have any more
distance to yourself into your own work
so if you've up for years and and and
sometimes you have success for three
four five years and you get the film k
that will happen till our delivery dies
I will have only success in my life and
then then you you lose any kind of
reflection any kind of distance and i
have also many friends in the literature
in the arts on the actor side a lot of
actors who really only want to be loved
by the audience and if ratings are
slipping down and they don't get any
more jobs for many of them in a special
agent discussion to say where where do I
stand and that happened so that happened
and and it took nearly one year of you
took a timeout a very long time took a
timeout and I restarted focusing i
restarted my my personal life ready to
take your time out every day and every
day i have two hours when we are
finishing here's a show i will have two
hours between six and eight really go to
my room just do nothing just sing about
the day today to sports and then go for
dinner and and and in those days i went
for dinner after the last meeting so i
was from nine to midnight it was yeah it
was it was a full lifetime so our
chopped and and and that's not working
with me anymore you were top employer i
am yeah absolutely sure because then you
start to have the imagination everybody
works as you know I have no family many
many many many very good people in my
company they have families and I have to
learn and I had to learn to respect that
their their time is to spend their time
with a family with their kids and so on
and I learned it and now it's a very
easy for me to say okay and then do it
okay you take the two hours off every
day that's a lot of time two hours yeah
it is really indeed it's a lot of time
yeah yeah but you are still working very
very very hard indeed and one of that
you've got it you've got a new project
that you're working on I know which as
far as I understand it's going to be not
just a free part
a series it's gonna be an eight-part
series on the life of adult which until
recently was like almost taboo terapia
yeah it's taboo territory and I did it
because there was a very interesting
book from Thomas labor Hitler's first
war which are rats and a very good
journalist praised the book and I read
it and there are so many interesting
informations about the life of art of
Hitler about his personal structure it
gives a fully new picture about his
personality and and you know I have
through the success in the last year's
there's a certain interest with two
colleagues one is sitting in London the
other person sitting in France we were
we were talking about Hitler project for
about 10 years and now I had the feeling
that time could be okay with all these
new informations we got and after the
film's we have done in an international
co-production to go on and hopefully it
will be a quality picture as I
understand it from what you're saying
what you're going to do is you're going
to portray Adolf Hitler not as a demon
but as a as a human being um as well I
would say for me he is a demon and to
get the bigger life behind him doesn't
at all make him a saint or make him
anything in this direct no no way and I
mean the balance we have to find is
really to say you have the demon you
have you have the the most terrible
personality putting putting crime all
over putting death all over but I want
to understand the psychology behind him
why drama people so easily followed him
that the basic thing about
then our chamak you grew up with her
with this man in your living room
effectively yeah I didn't I mean nobody
tell us who explained the legend to us
the legend in Germany in my generation
was I mean he was a first guy really in
telling the people about nature upon
animal life and he was we have the
Korean party I would say he was a first
Green Party member in his his beliefs
and and he was fascinating it was it was
not only the crazy television show man
looks a little bit totally nuts but he
was he was a fascinating personality
praying the subjects of nature how do we
behave against environment is he
environment important for us what
happens to nature in the next decades he
was the first person on TV and in real
life putting this on the agenda and the
German people he was the first one I
would say worldwide with his television
show he saw that in many countries that
the not himself but the but the
documentary parts was salt world over
and he's a fascinating personality and
her misery did you ever meet him no okay
nobody i met his part of his family yeah
ah and you met them because because we
are shooting his lifetime story starting
in october in in south africa yeah okay
um justjust for me it is a source of
constant fascination when way to one
we're making the kind of films that you
make when people are making those kind
of films and you've made so many of them
I often wonder we're talking about mr.
Jim McKeon and he won an Oscar for a
documentary film yeah why do you not
conclude sometimes that a documentary
film would be a better way of
transporting reality than a than a drama
a feature film yeah you know the
interesting thing is I first of all I
came from journalism and then I started
in Munich oh I switched from the fiction
croup the documentary crew by was I was
four years in the documentary section of
the school and you know all of the films
in the last year's they were always
correspondent together always put
together with a documentary afterwards
if you had
generation voir you have two documentary
on such a TF sites after the film and in
the last year's i also used parts of
documentaries within the film so i
really try if you talk about
authenticity yeah if you talk about real
feelings in those days i really try to
match it with material i can get even in
generation war we had a lot of material
in from charman from from from water and
sean and it was under and it was
overlaid with some with a struggling /
voice from from for Garko who was
playing here the main actor none so i
used it so i used it many many times
okay let's draw a conclusion a wee
little bit you've made all these movies
lots of them lots of movies about german
history the German news magazine Der
Spiegel called you the person in charge
of significance in German television
yeah so grant idoia describe the impact
you've had I would say Joanna dilorenzo
from his editor of the tide he told me
that two weeks ago I really think if you
take all the films i have made in the
last 10 12 years if you take trace and
if it takes out and bag i mean
Stauffenberg was also seen by tom cruise
before he met his movie if you take all
the things I've done about if it takes
the tomb about the introspection how
people live Jewish tend to have very
very good mood I loved it yeah it was
based on over telecoms book I would
really say if I put together the
audience's we talked about millions of
people having seen these programs it
surely has an impact of how about how
people in Germany are talking about
their history and their personal
memories in their history so hopefully
it has a positive aspect to say we can
talk more openly about our lives here in
Germany ok checking up that point we
normally have a quiz at this stage in
the show I'm gonna give you one question
yeah do we learn from history or repeat
it
I was here alone that's good news I hope
you're right I hope you're right that's
your lot with the the charming the
thought-provoking nikka Hawkman there's
more talking Germany including my blog
blog on our archived on our website have
a look at that but for now I'm just
going to say it's been a great show if
you've enjoyed it as much as I have come
back next week just bye-bye
you
you